>>presenter: Thanks everyone for coming today.
We have author George Dyson here to talk about
his upcoming book, or brand new book Turing’s
Cathedral: The Origins of the Digital Universe.
The creation stories of revolutionary technologies
is pretty deeply embedded in American culture.
We all learned very young about Benjamin Franklin’s
experiments with electricity and Thomas Edison
work on the light bulb, however, the story
of the invention of the computer, which is
arguably going to have much, a far greater
impact even though it’s based functionally
on those earlier technologies, is largely
missing from our collective knowledge.
Dyson’s new work sheds important light on
this and, on this creation of this and, uh,
this wonderful invention and how the digital
universe exploded in the aftermath of World
War II.
So, besides going deep into the early history
of the computer Turing’s Cathedral also offers
a series of provocative suggestions as to
where the digital universe may be headed next.
And so without further ado, let’s welcome
George Dyson.
[Applause]
>>George Dyson: Thank you.
It’s great to be here and see everybody working.
I come here every summer for Sci-Fu but in
the old days of Sci-Fu, sort of, we mingled
with the Google people that was part of the
idea but now Sci-Fu sort of isolated and we
don’t really see the people who are working,
we’re separated from the Sci-Fu people.
But I was here seven years ago, in fact, that’s
where the title of this book comes from and
I’ll explain that a little later.
And, I’m coming to this; I just have to say
this in all honesty, from totally left field.
I’m not a computer scientist, I’m not, I
dropped out of high school at age sixteen
and have no credentials that I’m interested
in things, I get curious about them and sort
of obsessed.
So I actually, by trade, I’m a boat builder.
I design and build boats.
And I am best known, far beyond anything in
computing history or anything else, because
I lived in a tree house for three years.
It was 95 feet up in a Douglas Fir Tree.
So that’s half way.
The bottom of the tree would be down at about
the floor.
That’s the house.
And in that tree house I read lots of books.
I had time.
I had time on a scale that no one can imagine
today.
You know, no e-mail, no distractions.
I read the entire 6,000 pages of Cooks Journals
one winter and then I came down.
And so I’m gonna thank a few people.
The book that I’m here for was published
yesterday, so it’s still, still a new thing.
First of all, my sister Esther, who some of
you probably know.
She’s played a role in a lot of the start
ups here and in Silicon Valley she actually,
I think, had some of the original investment
in Google at the very beginning.
There she is with her friend Bill in 1984.
And Esther was very kind to sort of extract
her brother from the Canadian wilderness and
bring me down to her, at that time she produced
the annual conference for the computer, it
was actually called in the beginning the Rosen
Electronics Forum.
It dealt mainly with semiconductors and suddenly
the main application for semiconductors became
the personal computer.
So she introduced me to this world and I got
to see what was going on.
And it brought me back to my childhood when
I was a young child there was a guy named,
my father worked at this placed called The
Institute for Advanced Study in Princeton,
but not part of the university, my mother
worked there too.
And most of those scientists were doing completely
boring things.
They worked on pencil and paper and maybe
they wrote on the chalkboard and erased it
the next day.
But Johnny Von Neumann had a building out
back where he was building a computer.
And it was not the first computer, it’s impossible
to get the people, you know, discussing and
trying to sell this book, to not say, “George’s
book is about the first computer.” It’s
not the first computer.
There were many, many computers before this
computer.
It was one of the first computers to have
a two dimensional speed of light address matrix
which is the world that you guys are all living
in today, where you can give a numerical coordinate
and get back a string of bits.
That was the thing that was new and that’s
what Von Neumann saw.
The model was Turing, Alan Turing's one dimensional
model and Von Neumann made it two dimensional,
that’s sort of the key moment in history
I’m trying to look at.
Not who invented the first computer, we’re
gonna argue about that forever.
You know, we’ll learn by arguing about it,
but it sort of gets pointless after a while.
So in 1984 just after I came down from the
tree house, I wrote this piece about Von Neumann
trying to give it to the people at my sister’s
conference, who really were not interested.
They were interested in whether DOS, which
sort of flavor of DOS would win next year.
So nothing happened.
But eventually this became this book, Darwin
Among the Machines, which was probably too
far ahead of its time but still in print.
And looks at this very large description of
where did this digital universe come from
on the long side?
In this book, I take it back to Thomas Hobbes
in the 17th century.
One of the people who appreciated this book
was Charles Simonyi from Xerox PARC, right
across the street here.
And that’s Charles in Budapest, Hungary with
a holographic bust of Johnny Von Neumann,
who is a national hero in Hungary.
And it was Charles who said, “George, you
know you should go dig this stuff out.” He
sort of sensed that I had a passion for excavating
digital archeology.
He’s the guy who pulled the strings to open
the doors to the history of advanced study
where there archives had been kept closed
to outside researchers since 1946.
And I happened to come, be with Charles when
he came to Google for the first time.
We were riding a bus together to an event
here.
And we drove up, and he was still at Microsoft
then, and we drove up in front of building
43, and what he said, which I can probably
repeat now, not at the time, cause he’s left
Microsoft, but he said, “Oh shit!
Building 43, we’re screwed.” Cause he thought
you guys already had 43 buildings.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: And you were only 2 years
old.
So Charles sent me on this path ten years
ago to go and try to find the documents of
really happened.
And the path always ends if you, if you’re
interested in history you sort of, you start
reading books that are gateway drugs.
Books lead you to libraries.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: And libraries lead you to
archives.
And then the final, sort of the heroine of
the whole thing, is eventually you get to
stuff that is not even the archives and that’s,
that’s what I do now.
This is the filing cabinet belonging to Johnny
Von Neumann’s daughter in Ann Arbor Michigan.
It’s always next to the water heater in the
basement.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: All of John Von Neumann’s
papers went the library of Congress, but this
filing cabinet didn’t and his daughter said,
you know, “You should come to Ann Arbor,
maybe, and take a look.” She didn’t, nobody
had looked.
I opened, and to me as a historian, the most
interesting, sort of, dark period of technology
history is like between 1937, just before
World War II and Sputnik.
After Sputnik we started documenting everything
really well.
But there’s sort of a dark period where we
don’t really know what happened.
So I opened that bottom drawer and it’s all
the letters back and forth, both directions
between Johnny and Klara from 1937 to when
he died in 1957.
And Von Neumann when he built this machine,
he needed to write the code for it, there
was nobody who did that kind of thing, so
he taught Klara how to write the codes.
So she wrote all the early codes and these
letters were all back and forth.
He’s, like there he’s at Los Alamos, she’s
in Washington D.C.
And there she’s at Aberdeen where the ENIAC
was, so she’s writing codes for the ENIAC
and he’s, uh, at Oak Ridge laboratory, nuclear
laboratory in Tennessee.
So all this stuff was there, half in Hungarian,
but Bela Bolobas and his wife Gabriella translated
it for me, so that, that’s the source of
this book.
When, until then I was struggling, then I
had the raw material to really bring this
story to life.
And Klara was a fantastic writer, even though
English was a second language, her journals
of coming to America and learning to code
these computers and seeing it all are just,
if you read the book I think you’ll find
she’s the voice that really keeps it all
going.
In Seattle, at the University Towers Hotel,
he gets invited to give the dance lectures
in 1940 at University of Washington and they
drive across America, you know, on Route 66
in his V8 Cadillac coupe and it’s all there
in the journals, it’s fantastic.
They stop at a bar in Nevada, and a guy comes
into the bar with a mule and the bartender
gives the mule a bucket of beer.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: And the other source of, the
sort of, real life to this story was a crazy
brilliant Italian, Norwegian mathematical
viral geneticist Nils Aal Barricelli, who
the moment even before Von Neumann got the
machine running, 1959 Baricelli writes to
Von Neumann from Norway saying he wants to
come and run numerical evolution experiments
on this machine.
And the machine is being built to hydrogen
bomb, hydro dynamic calculations.
So Von Neumann makes a deal, well you can
have the bomb guys sort of work all night
but they still fade out and go home at 2 or
3 in the morning and Baricelli gets the machine
the rest of the night.
And he has a knack for keeping, even with
no engineers he often keeps it going, you
know, until daylight.
So, now, I’ve been working on this five years,
I had a book contract for two years, it’s
what you get from publishers is two years,
I’m now, now really two years overdue and
I still haven’t started writing the book
and the publisher, they’re gonna cancel my
contract.
So I finally started writing this by putting
these slides together and I went and found,
“Okay I can find the notebook.
I wrote the first word.
It was gonna be called Baricelli’s Universe,
but then the publishers, well, “Who’s Baricelli,
nobody knows?” So that’s why Turing got
the title.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: Using the wonders of, you
know Photoshop; you can actually erase the
context and see the second, so here, what’s
the first sentence I wrote.
“It’s Princeton New Jersey where this took
place.
In summer is so hot and humid that the atmosphere
has been described as quote “Like the inside
of a dog’s mouth.” It’s sensing it’s the
worse place in the world to try and build
an electrostatic memory computer, but they
did.” And that sentence actually survived.
It’s the opening sentence of Chapter 2.
So I had the first sentence in the book, but
no book.
Now I work in a bar, old bar in Bellingham
Washington so I could lay out, you know, one
by one, the chapters.
So Turing comes into the picture because,
you know, the conception of all this goes
back to Turing.
Turing came to Princeton in 1936, he stayed
for two years.
He worked fairly closely with Johnny Von Neumann
who always credited Turing.
Von Neumann always said, “The original idea
was Turing’s, all I did was implement it.”
And why we now have an incredible divisive
battle going on between people who think the
American’s get too much credit, people who
think that British get too much credit and
at the time both sides were absolutely collaborating
with each other.
There was not rivalry until, sort of, the
historians who came in later.
In 1950 Alan Turing who’s very interested
in the, the whole idea of what we now call,
artificial intelligence, he starts asking
the question, “Can machines think?” And
immediately people are saying, “Oh no, don’t
go there.
That’s sort of playing God and only God and
people can think.
How can machines think?” And he answers that
question, I think, in a very tactful way.
“When we build intelligent machines, we’re
not creating souls we’re creating the mansions
for the souls that only he can create.” And
I think that’, that’s how I feel.
And then it’s 2005, Chris DiBona who invites
me here to Google, cause 19-, 2005 is sixty
years from when this project started.
So I came and gave a similar afternoon talk
on that anniversary.
And when I walked in here I got sort of the
engineering tour of what you’re doing in
the basement and other places.
I saw the first of the Mars data coming in
and stuff.
And then as I walked out after giving the
talk I just, this phrase came to my mind,
“This is not, what you’re doing here at
Google, that’s not Turing’s mansion, this
is Turing’s Cathedral.” And that’s, so
that’s, the title of this book actually comes,
not from this right here, I gave the talk
in the cafeteria, it was very bad acoustics.
[Laughter]
>> George Dyson: But that’s, that’s the
source of Turing’s Cathedral.
And that’s not in the book, that’s sort
of the back story that people don’t know.
The front story is just cathedral, cathedrals
are built by large numbers of anonymous people
and that’s how computing is.
Everybody’s putting a little brick here a
little brick there and in the end you get
this cathedral.
So finally, uh, I’ve sort of got the beginnings
of a book.
The subtitle was A Creation Myth.
I didn’t want people to think I was telling,
I didn’t want to be held to telling the truth.
I just wanted to tell what I, the best of
my knowledge, what I think happened.
I’m not interested so much in who is first,
but what really happened.
And we lack a, we live in this digital universe,
but we don’t really have a common creation
myth about how it started.
And there’s three things that as an author
that you’re terrified of hearing from your
publisher.
The first one if your rejection letter, “It’s
a lovely book but we can’t publish it.”
The second one is, “You’re late and we’re
gonna cancel your contract.” And the third
one is, “We have a cover and we think you
will like it.”
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: Every time I’ve got that
message from publishers they’re just horribly
disappointing.
Some of the covers I’ve had for my books
are just excruciating, but in this case, it
was true.
They, Pantheon, their designer, Peter Mendelsund,
came up with this cover that was so brilliant.
I mean, I loved it, nothing got changed.
The idea, sort of, cover is punched, like
the punch cards, at random machine.
So you see, you know the digital, there’s
the transition between analog and digital,
it’s there in the physical cover of the book.
And you won’t get that in an EBook.
[Laughter]
>> George Dyson: 1912 Turing was born, so
exactly 100 years ago Sara Turing, his mom,
was five months pregnant and we’re counting
down to the centenary of Alan Turin, who deserves
all the, you know, he had a tragic life.
He, people say he did commit suicide, we think
he committed suicide.
We’re not sure, but he died of cyanide poisoning
under ambiguous circumstances at the age of
41.
And the opening page of this book is a tribute
to Leibniz who in 1697 reminded us that it
was not made for those who sell oil or sardines.
Which, modern translation would be, Google
isn’t all about ads, there’s other stuff
going on.
And what I’m going to do now, because the
book has all these, again they kept the 82
illustrations I gave them.
I’m just going to show you the illustrations
in color, but if you have the book they’ll
be there in black and white.
So they’re all very carefully chosen.
That is the dawn of the digital universe,
or of the modern digital, we certainly had,
we had punch cards long before that but this
is one of the first of these electronic memory
tubes where the bits actually are charged
spots on the face of the tube.
Now, you know, we have solid state memory
and we display it on a display.
And in this case, the actual memory were spots
of light on the face of a glass tube, so you
could see, there were 40 of these tubes, you
could see the computation preceding.
This is a scrap of paper I found in another
one of these basements by the water heaters,
Julian Bigelow’s basement.
It was crumpled up and saved, it says, “Orders
let a word 40 bd.” So that dates it from
before they started using the word bit, binary
digits.
“The two orders, each order equal C of A,
a command.” They give the coordinates and
an address.
And to me that’s Moses coming off of a mountain
and saying “Let there be the command line.”
[Laughter]
>> George Dyson: And we take that completely
for granted.
How could we, you know, was there ever a word
without commandments?
Well, there was and that’s the beginning
of it.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: And the engineers, no one
was supposed to talk about the fact that they
were actually designing hydrogen bombs, but
here is, this is a late night log book.
So this is significant because this is March
3rd 1953, so this is the first night that
Baricelli starts writing his first ever, he
calls them numerical simbi organisms, now
we call them digital organisms.
So he stops and turns it over to the AEC bomb
people and that’s the log entry of that transition.
So they were, on the one, why Von Neumann
was so amazing that he not only, he was trying
to build a machine, a device that could destroy
all life on planet Earth.
A hydrogen bomb is the most evil thing that
has ever been created and at the same time
he was talking about creating a new kind of
digital life.
So there’s two very opposite things were
going on in the same, you know, it was 5 kilobytes
of memory was all they had.
That’s Alan Turing at age 5 and Johnny Von
Neumann at age 7.
So there’s, very much, complimentary personalities
between these two people.
And, so it irritated me how all these historians
still are arguing about, “What did Von Neumann
take from Turing?
Why didn’t he give Turing credit?
Did he read Turing’s paper?
People say, “Oh no, he didn’t read Turing’s
paper.” So I just thought I’d go look in
Von Neumann’s library.
Turing’s paper was published in the proceedings
of the London mathematical society.
That’s the volume it was in.
When you go to the institute library all the
volumes are absolutely untouched, mint, hardly
been opened except volume 42.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: And it’s clearly, you know,
it’s been read so many times it’s completely
fallen apart.
They didn’t have Xerox machine so they just,
yeah.
And the engineers I spoke with, the few that
were left said, “Yeah, Von Neumann, we all
had to read that paper.
That’s what we were doing was building a
Turing machine.” So I think that answers
the question.
And Turing was working in England, he was
in Princeton, but he went back to help with
the war effort.
Actually he saved, I think, I think he saved
England from being conquered by Germany because
he helped break the Nazi U-boat codes.
We forget how desperate England was, I mean
we were sending supplies to England but we
hadn’t entered the war yet and the Germans
were sinking the supply ships.
So he also, the engineers with him built,
what was effectively a Turing machine called
The Colossus built largely by Thomas, Tommy
Flowers, who came from the Post Office Electronic
Research Station and it was able to compare
coded sequences stored in vacuum tube memory
with the intercepted coded sequences stored
on paper tape and so it really, it was, who,
in fact you could say this was the archetype
of a search engine, searching for patterns
in data.
There’s Turing getting on a bus, he was a
long distance runner, he’s going to a marathon.
Von Neumann with his machine that was built
by Julian Bigelow and it had twenty of these
tubes on each side, so each of these cans
had a 32x32 array of bits and there were 40
cans.
So effectively they had a matrix that was
32x32x40 bits, which is five kilobytes.
That’s one half second of an Mp3.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: They did this in the middle
of New Jersey which is also, and sort of the
back story to all of this is always fascinating,
so the, that’s the headwaters of the [inaudible]
and New York is here and so Philadelphia is
there and so this has been settled in the
17th century.
And a guy named Henry Greenland opens a tavern
there at the arrow so people going back and
forth on that trail can stop and get a beer
and change their horses or spend the night.
And then the Quakers led by William Penn,
they’re trying to get as far away from New
York and Philadelphia is possible.
So they also settle there, and they build
a Quaker meeting house.
So you have this tavern and you have the Quaker
meeting house.
And the tavern became Princeton University
and the Quaker meeting house that land became
the Institute for Advanced Study.
It only changed hands twice, from the Penn
family to the Olden family to the Institute.
Then they built this fabulous headquarters,
the sort of Google Plex of its time.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: And this was built in 1939
right when things really went bad in Europe,
so this became a refuge for all the, mainly
Jewish scientists fleeing Germany who were
given refuge here.
I mean, it was incredible stupidity on the
part of the Germans to kick out the smartest
people who, who were largely given refuge
by Oswald Veblen who American but saw what
was happening and set up a community to aide
refugee scientists and broke all the rules
like you guys probably do with H1 visas to
get these people in despite, forget that at
that time Princeton University had a quota
against Jewish faculty and Jewish students
so the Institute played a very strong role.
That’s Norbert Wiener who sort of coined
the word, or took the word from Ampere but
then re coined the word cybernetics.
Abraham Flexner who really, the Institute
was his idea and it was based on the concept
of the usefulness of useless knowledge, that
if you just let people work on whatever they
want, they’re gonna come up with useful things.
I think, what’s the policy here, still 10%?
Or is it 20?
20, okay.
So this was hundred percent.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: It’s all, it’s all [inaudible].
And the founders, the people who put in the
money, they were sort of the [inaudible] family,
the department store owners, the Bambergers
who believed in that this would further the
cause of social justice which in a way maybe
it has if the computer actually did what they
intended.
The first six math professors including Einstein
and Herman Weyl as well as [Inaudible], Johnny
Von Neumann and Oscar Morgenstern who together
formulated the modern version of game theory,
theory of games and economic behavior.
And Einstein and Gödel, Kurt Gödel the logician
who gets, in the standard histories gets no
credit, there’s no involvement with computing
at all.
But actually his office was above von Neumann.
And I think in many ways the whole concept
of numerical addressing that you could address
strings of bits, manipulate the numerical
addresses and then be manipulating the underlying
streams is very similar to what Gödel did
in his, sort of, incompleteness proof.
And I think he actually contributed more than
what we actually think.
Johnny Von Neumann at age 11 with his cousin.
He loved weapons from the beginning.
So here they’re visiting an Austro-Hungarian
artillery gun emplacement in 1915 and he’s
the kid sitting on the barrel of the cannon.
There at a wedding with his, uh, his cousin’s
wedding.
This stuff is all in it because so much of
understanding why this happened and how it
happened is that, what was going on in Budapest
between World War I and World War II, why
did all these, you know, why did Johnny Von
Neumann, Eugene Wigner, Leo Szilard, Edward
Teller and Paul Erdos, they all came out of
the same group of people in Hungary and ended
up here.
So Von Neumann was at the position at the
University of Berlin but then he could see
what was, he saw what was gonna happen and
left early, resigned his position, had a tremendous,
you know, sense of humor.
That’s Princeton, that’s a cocktail party
in the 1930’s.So all these people are from
Budapest.
That’s HP Robertson who at that time was
teaching quantum physics to Alan Turing, Alan
Turing was his student and, you know, I was
there as a child, I don’t ever remember meeting
Johnny Von Neumann, he had left to go work
for the Atomic Energy Commission while I was
still like two years old.
But I remember a cocktail party of my mom’s
when I was stuck in a crib, I was very unhappy
and a guy, a really cheerful mathematician
came in the room and talked to me and gave
me a sip of his drink.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: And I like to think, you know,
maybe that was, maybe that was my contact
with Von Neumann.
And these guys had so much fun at Los Alamos,
I mean, these are theoretical mathematicians
who never touched real hardware and then suddenly
they’re allowed to play with high explosives
in machine shops.
Dick Feynman standing on the left in 1949,
the photo taken by Nick Metropolis who developed
the Monte Carlo algorithm.
So they were intoxicated, I mean once Los
Alamos was over they weren’t gonna go back
to teaching calculus or anything like that.
They wanted, and the computer, that was the
next thing after.
So, they all got involved in the ENIACs.
The ENIAC which was oddly enough, it was what
we would now call a multiple core processor
where there were 20 parallel processors working
together and then they rewired it to turn
into more of a serial mode.
But it started out as multiple core architecture.
And von Neumann and his, the other engineers
put together this little book explaining how
to build a better computer, things like an
adder that we take totally for granted, they
had to figure it out.
The memory, the input output.
Vladimir Dvorkin another amazing character,
Russian emigre who escaped through the Russian
Arctic to America, you know, got a job in
New York and ended up bringing television
to, he’s really one of the two people that
brought television to American.
And he and Von Neumann partnered together
so the origin is this project, like meeting
number one is in Zworykin’s office and there’s
you see the fifth person down is John Tooke,
the statistician, the guy who gets tired of
saying binary digit and finally says, “come
on, let’s call them bits guys.” And then
we get bit.
Bernetta Miller, no institution functions
without a secretary who keeps everything going
and solves the problems and gets things done,
she was the fifth person in the United States
to get a pilot’s license and then her eyesight
started going bad so she ended up getting
a job at the institute and ran things.
So she did the hard work of keeping the computer
projects supplied and so on.
And, uh, then Oppenheimer fired her because
she kinda, I think she knew too much.
Acrivo Condopria Emmanuelise, Greek, so she
was 16 years old in Philadelphia, her father
couldn’t read or write English and her guidance
counselor told her she couldn’t go to the
college, there was no hope, but there was
this project if she moved to Pennsylvania
maybe she could work on it, and it was ENIAC,
so she became the ENIAC project secretary
and did such a good job that Herman Goldstein
and Johnny Von Neumann brought her to the
Institute at age 17.
And if you’re around this evening I’m doing
a discussion at the computer history museum
and she’s going to be there.
She’s one of the last persons left who really
is still, cause she was so young at the time,
she lives in Los Angeles and she’s come up
for this tonight and then another thing in
San Francisco tomorrow and that’s quite amazing,
that there’s still somebody left who, all
those famous reports, establishing the architecture
of all the machines used them, she’s the
person who typed those reports and got every
word right.
And she proofread my book.
It was just fantastic having her.
So she’s a lot of fun, I mean, and she didn’t
have her own computer until 2009, her daughter
got her a Mac.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: And some of the guys, Norman
Phillips, doing weather predictions, so they
worked on a bunch of problems including Jerry
Estrin who’s two of his daughters, one is
real principal in Cisco and Judy and Deborah
Estrin and both very active in, you know,
what’s happened in the next generation of
computing.
This machine was built with the expectation
what Zworykin promised that RCA would build
something called the Selectron, so this is
like you heard about how dinosaur, somewhere
there’s a dinosaur, the first dinosaur that
has feathers and that’s the, the mythical
transition from analog to digital.
That’s an analog vacuum tube with a 4,096
bit digital memory inside.
A pure digital matrix and so it’s the ancestor
of your USB stick but it never got built in
time but they built a machine waiting for
these things to plug in and then they never
materialized, so then they did the strange
hack with the cathode ray tubse.
But the architecture is established for this
the next, I think largely the reason that
we moved into the solid state age so fast
that when, you know, Fairchild and those people
started coming up with, with solid state devices
and memory.
The architecture had been expecting that from
the very beginning.
It’d been waiting for it for twenty or thirty
years so it just could plug right in.
In fact, my new Mac here has a solid state
drive so it’s actually a, it’s a selectron
machine.
So in England, in Manchester, where a very
clever group of British people were also with,
including Turing, were, they got a machine
running way before the people in Princeton,
that’s Frederic C Williams and Tom Kilburn,
they did the work of getting these, using
these spots of charge on the face of an oscilloscope
tube to work as memory and then the Princetonians
went over there and adopted and improved the
idea, they made it random access.
So that’s one, it’s a standard washer plus
an oscilloscope tube with an amplifier on
top.
So with the amplified the signal 30,000 times
and then if you’re lucky you can distinguish
between a 0 and a 1 in this tiny time interval
of point 7 microseconds.
Julian Bigelow was the engineer who built,
physically built the machine.
I think it’s an absolute work of art.
I mean, it’s built like a 40 cylinder diesel
engine with overhead valves intake, I mean,
it’s just essentially was an engine, it was
an engine for numbers and it, you know, there’s
one bit each of 1,040 bit words in each cell.
It’s just an absolutely brilliant design
as long as you know when it was working.
And there it is, it’s now, unfortunately,
was given to the Smithsonian but they don’t
even have it on display.
It’s often one of closed warehouses in Maryland
or somewhere.
[Pause]
>>George Dyson: It shouldn’t be and I hope
someone will, if I succeed in anything it
might be to get, you know it should be in
a computer history museum right here, they
have space for it and it’d be the perfect
place for it.
Julian Bigelow, Herman Goldstein, Robert Oppenheimer
who we think was against the hydrogen bomb
but was actually being quite supportive, Johnny
Von Neumann, all of the engineers that helped.
A lot of women who did the coding, there was
no place for them to live so Bigelow, who
would solve any problem, he went to upstate
New York, a place called Mineville and purchased
these war surplus barracks and cut them in
half and brought them down to Princeton by
rail.
That’s the first magnetic drive, so that’s
the ancestor of your hard disc.
It’s magnetic recording wire around two bicycle
wheels and they got 90,000 bits per second
input output outta that thing.
And that’s what a 40 bit word looks like,
I mean, it’s amazing how they, you know,
they were able to solve real problems with
sort of that, you know, that bad of digital
representation.
So, you know, they’re trying to get analog
stuff to behave in a digital way.
That’s the very first prototype shift register,
is a, we think like shift registers been there
forever, but it had, somebody had to, so they
went to about 7 different versions of shift
registers before saying ,”This is how it’s
gonna be.” And now that’s how it is.
Physical work was done by high school girls
and students.
They were called wiremen, the people who had
to actually had to do the wiring and soldering.
That’s the wiring guide ran for the shift
register, it’s really brilliantly designed.
Jim Pomerantz with a pipe and Julian Bigelow
in the middle, Willis Ware who’s still alive
who played a big role, went from the Princeton
to Rand and, uh, he was explaining computer
architecture.
The first flow diagram that I’ve been able
to find, maybe someday somebody with find
another one, but this was 1947 they’re doing
a Monte Carlo hydrogen bomb problem.
And that’s Stan Ulam who really the Monte
Carlos sort of named after.
He was a gambler, he’s waiting, that’s the
weekly poker game at Los Alamos and that’s
Nick Metropolis who we owe a huge debt to,
I mean, he, you know, one of the founding
fathers of computer science who’s again,
not, never took a huge amount of credit for
himself.
Klara, Johnny’s second wife, who was the
champion figure skater of Hungary, national
figure skating champion at age 14, paid no
attention in school but Johnny taught her
to do the coding.
That’s their trip to Florida in his V8 Cadillac.
And Stan Ulam and Francois who both, you know,
they both lost their entire families to the
holocaust in Europe and escaped to the United
States.
And you have to remember that when you try
and say, “Why were these people working on
these terrible, terrible weapons?” They were
working on these terrible weapons because
they believed we had to have the strongest
weapons on our side and also not publicly
known.
That’s Nick Metropolis’s Los Alamos badge,
now he’s playing first game of computer chess
against the MANIAC at Los Alamos.
Notice it’s a 6 by 6 chess board.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: So to make it simpler so they
play without bishops and they called it anti-clerical
chess.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: And the moves are, the input
output is still punch paper tape, so the machine
was called MANIAC for mathematical numerical
integrated and computer.
But back to Von Neumann, he had at Los Alamos
he worked closely with Klaus Fuchs and they
were actually working on a hydrogen bomb design
and then it, Klaus Fuchs turned out to be
this, he was the Russian spy, he was the Russian
plant.
So Von Neumann knew more than he could say,
he really believed the Russians might be half
way there and we had to catch up.
So it’s not to justify what, well it is to
justify what he did.
So there’s Von Neumann at the Grand Canyon
and his mule is facing the opposite direction
of everybody else.
And Klara and Francois Ulam, Claire Ulam,
who’s still alive, Stan Ulam her dad who
was from Poland, Johnny and the Ulam’s, so
all these people let me into their basements
and the Ulam’s sort of filing cabinet.
There’s this beautiful drawing by George
Kamov with sort of the actors in the hydrogen
bomb drama in 1951.
That’s Joseph Stalin with the bomb, Oppenheimer
looking like a saint, whether he was or not
and Stan Ulam spitting, Edward Teller in the
middle and George Kamov pulling the tail of
a cat.
And those drawings are about they have some
significance as physics relating to the different
approaches that were being taken to try and
solve the hydrogen bomb problem but nobody
is left who can explain that to me, I don’t
understand it.
Von Neumann and Vera Von Braun the, you know,
the rocket pioneer from Germany.
Lewis Fry Richardson, another thread of this
whole thing, a meteorologist in England who
worked on a, during, coding the hydrodynamic
behavior of the atmosphere in a cellular model
which is how we actually do it today.
He said we would need 64,000 human computers
to exchange, do the partial differential equating
as fast as the weather itself and that’s
about what really happened.
And then he answered the artificial intelligence
questions, you know, “Do we have artificial
intelligence?” Yeah, sure we do, it’s just
a question of how much.
So this is a non-deterministic circuit, you
can’t predict what states it’s gonna be
in.
Illustrating the mind having the will that’s
capable of only two ideas, and that’s, again,
what I think you guys are doing here at Google.
You’re just, you’re building an enormous
nondeterministic circuit that instead of the
only capable of two ideas is capable of all
the ideas that people have ever had.
And that’s, you know, that’s why the book
is called Turing’s Cathedral.
That’s the expedition to do the, that’s
the first day they actually knew they got
a 24 hour weather prediction in less than
24 hours of processing time.
And then it went very fast, if you look at
what they did, we’re just about at the end,
in this 5 kilobytes of memory; they worked
on five big problems that were confrontationally
kind of similar but across completely different
scales of time.
So they worked on the questions of nuclear
explosions where everything is over in nanoseconds,
that’s it.
And you’ve got the answer, it may take weeks
to get it, but the phenomena itself is very
short.
Von Neumann was extremely interested in shock
waves which are on the time scale of seconds
to maybe minutes but a short period of time.
And then they looked at meteorology, which
is over periods of hours, days and weeks.
If it’s months then it sort of become climate.
And Nils Barricelli showed up to work on biological
evolution over periods of centuries, thousands
of years, and another German refugee, Martin
Schwarzschild showed up and did a huge number
of stellar evolution codes, looking at the
evolution of stars over billions of years.
So it’s five problems that span, sort of,
entire span of time in five kilobytes, quite
amazing.
These are all five problems that are still
big problems today.
In the middle is the scales in seconds, so
you got 26 rows of magnitude from 10 to minus
8 to 10 to the 17th seconds.
If you look, you know, what is humanely perceivable
you have a blink of an eye, a third of a second
to a 90 year life span.
And in the exact middle is one day, sort of
one, you know, one 8 hour day at work is like
the middle of the perceivable universe and
that I’m still, I’m puzzled by this.
I don’t know if it’s because we’re observers
in the middle that’s always gonna be symmetrical.
But why, you know why are we in the middle
of that time scale?
And what computers have done, they have expanded
our perception.
We’ve gone from the blink of an eye being
the shortest interval to, you know, we measure
our memory in nanoseconds.
So computers have just expanded our range
in all directions.
And the fast side gets all the attention cause
you need fast computers to, you know, to build
bombs, to beat the other guy in high frequency
trading and that kind of thing.
But the long term scale, I think, is equally
important.
In the long term it may be just as important
to the survival of our species and civilization
and even life on earth that we have computers
that, you know, monitor climate of hundreds
of years and make long term decisions that
we as human beings might not make for ourselves.
So von Neumann was very interested in life
and biology, there’s Baricelli who thought
totally in binary.
They didn’t have any, real operating systems,
no language no nothing.
It was just straight, I mean most of the guys
worked at hexadecimal but he worked straight
raw binary code so that’s one of his universes.
Alan Turing in 1951 where he is now working
on building a commercial machine and he insisted
that that commercial machine had to have a
source of nondeterministic electronic noise.
The machine had to be able to guess, you know,
he didn’t want a deterministic machine he
wanted a machine that was capable of making
guesses and mistakes.
Julian Bigelow who would be 100 years old
next year, soon as von Neumann died the Institute
pulled the plug on the project so 12 o’ clock
midnight July 15th 1958 that’s the last entry
in the log book and it was so sad for, cause
Julian he had such a rapport with this machine,
it was running fine.
He had problems stacked up to work on but
they pulled the plug on him and it was over.
In one of these basements, you know, I was
digging around there was a box that the surface
of the box was World War II teleprinter manuals
that I should of just, you know, left it but
I dug to the bottom of the box and the bottom
of the box was a box of punch cards with the
entire, uh, source and output code for one
of Baricelli’s digital numerical origin experiments.
And on, in there was a note and the note from
the engineer to, you know, Mr. Baricelli,
“There must be something about this code
that you haven’t explained yet.” And when
I found that sentence it was like, you know,
walking in here and finding the title I knew
that, that was gonna be the last, those would
be the last words in the book because that’s
what Turing came to this problem the beginning
from and was trying to answer a very abstract
mathematical problem called the Entscheidungs
Problem, the decision problem of whether by
looking at any string of code can you predict
whether it is a provable formula or not.
And the answer is no and he got to that answer
by inventing what we called the Turing machine.
It was a very sort of strange accident in
that doing this very abstract problem he helped
to develop this very concrete technology.
And the Entscheidungs Problem is still what
allows us to know that, and you guys know
it all too well, that you can’t tell by looking
at a code, you have to run the code to really
know what it’s gonna do.
There’s always gonna be strange unpredictable,
not just bugs, but that’s a very fundamental
part of this world we live in that it’s never
gonna be completely determined it’s gonna
always, there’s always gonna be some loudness
there, I think that’s important.
And so it brings us back to what Leibniz imagined
in the beginning, this purely digital universe
where everything was binary code.
The last picture in the book is me, that’s
me, no that’s Esther sucking her thumb.
[Laughter]
>>George Dyson: In 1954, so I’m sort of here
as the, not the eyewitness, but to remind
everybody where, you know, where this started
in these sort of very, uh, far thinking ideas
and the people that started it.
They weren’t just trying to do one problem
they were trying solve all problems.
And thanks to all the people who so generously
let me go through their stuff.
And that’s it.
We have time for a few questions.
[Applause]
>>presenter: Thanks again for an absolutely
fascinating talk and in depth history of this
relatively mythical creation in time, um,
I was actually wondering you mentioned, you
know, they’ve got these myths about the inventor
from electricity and the experiments with
that and then the invention of the light bulb.
How do you think some day that this story
will boil down to, you know, a very maybe
metaphor, but a concept that even children
will be able to accept and embrace as far
as the foundations and beginning of modern
computation?
>>George Dyson: Yeah, that’s a good question.
And it’s such a problem because people always
want to assign it to one person, they want
to say, “Thomas Edison invented the light
bulb.” Or “Benjamin Franklin invented electricity.”
We somehow, so I don’t know how to, I mean,
that’s why I called the book Turing’s Cathedral
because I’m trying to give credit to Turing
for this very abstract idea but not say that
so and so invented the computer.
And there are books, I mean, if you look at
how many books there are on who invented the
computer and the arguments.
I don’t know what we’re gonna arrive at
as a sort of cultural myth.
I was trying to give a bigger picture of this
is a very group effort that brought us into
a numerical universe in a way that, you know,
there was this very fundamental transition.
It’s like we don’t argue about who invented
the language, right?
Nobody’s arguing, “Oh it was this guy.
No it was his uncle that said the first sentence.”
We don’t care, just it’s something that
happened but there are huge numbers of academic
scientists studying the evolution of language
but we don’t try to say that somebody invented
it.
>> presenter: While we wait for any other
questions, I did have one other question.
You said that there was a bit of pathetic
or a sense of transition from those two dimensional
universe you described to a three dimensional.
Can you give us a glimpse of that, obviously
I look forward to reading it in the book,
but any sense of what you mean by stepping
in to a three dimensional universe?
>>George Dyson: Sure.
I love to talk about the future.
I’m a historian so I’m sort of licensed
to talk about the past not the future.
But I think there is, sort of and this is
making a very simplified generalization, but
the Turing model was one dimensional , the
on Neumann implementation was this, which
still you know, if you have an IP address,
that’s a coordinate in a two dimensional
space.
That’s why we have the at sign in the middle.
And, but what the internet has done is give
us this more three dimensional world where
machines can be connecting with the same data
at the same time.
It’s no longer flat.
So it’s become three dimensional but we still
write most of our programs in a three dimensional
way.
I think the future and the exciting thing
about what’s going on here, companies like
Facebook, all the companies that are doing
well, is that they’re building new layers
of very different kinds of computation on
top of that, we’re not gonna replace the
von Neumann sub street it’s like DNA, it’s
there.
We can do other things on top of it and a
lot of what’s being done, and it’s an almost
unmentionable word to say, but a lot of what
you guys are doing is analog computation.
And, I mean, if you look at the Facebook problem,
you got a small high school, everybody’s
changing girlfriends and boyfriends every
weekend, you cannot digitally code that, it’s
just too incomprehensibly complex.
But if you get everybody a little piece of
code and let them connect on Facebook the
map becomes a, you know it becomes a model
of itself.
And that’s analog computing.
Where the complexity is not in the code but
in the connections between the code and that’s
a lot of how Google works because, you know,
you’re finding the links.
It’s topology not digital sequence.
That’s good.
>>male #1: So you’ve already made a liar
of me.
I came here today planning to ask you how
come Leibniz and Gödel always fall out of
these discussions.
Why are they never made part of the story?
>>George Dyson: Oh I think it all goes back
to Leibniz.
>> male #1: But it all goes back to Leibniz
and Gödel clearly, um, he was asking the
questions.
I think there’s a subtlety that maybe people
asking questions in analog domain it’s not
obvious, to those of us in computing, that
these things map across into the digital make.
But, I was wondering, you know, this; I’m
trying to ask you something about the historical
process I think.
How is it that these great antecedents, the
people that pose the questions, don’t get
a very large slice of the credit themselves?
>>George Dyson: I don’t know.
I mean that’s the mystery of history.
And you can probably tell I like, I enjoy
sort of finding the people like Baricelli
who were completely ignored, you know, and
bringing them back to life.
And the same with Gödel, I think if you’re
looking for early computer plans and Gödel’s
1931 proof is in many ways, it’s a program,
it’s a, it’s quite amazing how much, and
the funny thing is that he was just sitting
there with all this going on around him and
he didn’t
>>male #1: But the point of amusement that
was when I was studying mathematics and the
assignment was like, go and reconstruct that
proof, it turned out the easiest method I
had to do was to write a LISP interpreter
in arithmetic.
And then everything followed.
>>George Dyson: Yeah.
That’s a very good question and I’m glad
I saved myself from me.
[Laughs]
>>presenter: Well, again, just make sure we
have a little bit of time left for book signing
and again make sure you talk to the book [inaudible]
people in the back.
Let’s give one more round of applause for
George Dyson.
[Applause]